with danny duffy on the mound and for
danny this is his fifth uh career start
against the cardinals and he has an
excellent strikeout to walk ratio
against the cardinals in his career
colton wong steps to the plate
who right over the outside edge todd
tishner rings him up there you go
challenge these hitters now you have to
throw it down the middle and he didn't
wang you got to go
two up two down for paul goldschmidt
and when i played i wanted a good pitch
that's a great spot there duffy a change
up away took care of those guys with no
trouble
this season at four starts carlos
martinez is winless
and he's trying to change that tonight
in game three of this series against
kansas city mind to see in its 20 stolen
basis stands at first salvador perez in
the batter's box
salve eaton hits it in the air to center
field it carries on bader all the way
back for a two run home run
wow talk about ambush in the first pitch
fastball salvador perez was sitting all
over
that carlos martinez fastball from out
of here molina
out to center and that's a base hit hit
number
1997 for yadier molina and it's a double
and with that double he is now tied with
johnny bench
on the all-time list at number eight
overall for catchers
jam shot
chance for two
and they got him duffy's going good
hunter dozier the man who caught the
ball
beginning the double play leads off and
he swings lifts one high in the air deep
right center field that's back to the
track and off the wall fielded by fowler
the throw goes into second and he's
trying to make third the throw over
there he's safe but i'll tell you even
better hustle by dozier good head for a
slide into third look at that nicely
done close now the royals have to turn
this into a run cordero with four hits
in 26 advance ground ball off the glove
with martinez it's gonna roll into short
right field and dozier's gonna score
you talk about a discouraging start for
a pitcher martinez got a ground ball if
he fields it cleanly there's no way the
dozier can sprint home
the royals now have them on first and
second base with nobody out and martinez
in dire straits here now he's facing the
hottest royal en salvador prez trailing
three nothing
look at this
deep left field and salvador perez has
driven in five runs in the first three
innings
man
who needs to steal and why would you
even steal when you got salvador perez
going back to back jacks this time he
try to change up and you can't hit it
much better than that and paul
goldschmidt will bat he struck out in
the first
on the ground to third franco throws
from foul territory in time to get
goldsmith wow
look at duffy getting some defensive
plays behind him tonight it's a
beautiful thing you when you're going to
the opponent's dugout and you throw off
your left foot shoot that's a hope and a
prayer and it worked but the wild pitch
puts a runner into scoring positions so
2-0 now on fowler long way to go in this
one
hit up the middle base hit
that'll bring in ronald revello and the
cardinals get on the board that makes it
6-1
2-2
swing and a miss he strikes out dylan
carlson so danny gets him on a change-up
that pitch has been working pretty well
for danny tonight
called strike three good change-up from
duffy he's been working for him tonight
he strikes out his fourth st louis does
score a run scott barlow comes out of
the royals bullpen his job
get the final out of this sixth inning
st louis is threatening they have loaded
the bases they've got brad miller coming
in to pinch it for angel rovello
the runners go
and miller rolls it up the first base
side dozier's there to cut him off and
tag him out so barlow comes in does an
excellent job the cardinals leave the
bases loaded
second walk by martinez
franchi cordero ball wants to yachty
they're telling him hey get your arm up
and they might go out and look at him
right now big time he looks like he's
something's barking here for carlos yeah
he's pointing to that left side
something definitely not right i would
assume that'd be it for him you bring it
ellis don't take any more chances and
that'll be it all right here is seth
ellis facing francie cordero
cordero with a nice wrist swing drives
it into deep right center field and that
is gone and the royals have hit their
third home run tonight
and they lead 9-1 in the sixth inning
and monday is gonna drive in a run
he's gonna dig for second and it'll make
it easily
on fowler and the royals have four
in the bottom of the sixth inning and
they lead 10-1
bronco will bat runners at first and
second two outs
michael franco gaps one right center
field the royals are gonna
really turn it on they will hold solaire
at third base franco goes into second
base with his 16th double
and the royals now have an 11-1 lead and
they are batting around just bashing
cardinal pitching tonight
look at this another one deep right
center field again and bader turns and
francie cordero
has hit two home runs tonight and he has
a career-high five rbis and the royals
lead 12-1
inside and dylan takes a walk loading
the bases now harrison bader
and that is ripped out to left center
off the bat of bader two runs will come
in to score and it cuts a lead to 12 to
three harrison bader with a single that
drives in two and matt carpenter is
going to pinch it for jake woodford
bader runs and that's a called third
strike carpenter doesn't like it but the
game is over the series is over and it's
a huge night for salvador perez and
francie cordero